>> Tucker: THE TECH COMPANY
AIRBNB RUN BY RICH PEOPLE USED
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION AND ITS
IMMIGRATION POLICY.
THEY DEBUTED A NEW AD THAT
RIDICULES THE PRESIDENT'S
COMMENTS ABOUT POOR AND
DANGEROUS COUNTRIES.
HERE'S PART OF IT.
[♪♪]
>> Tucker: WE'LL SEE YOU IN PART
-- PORT-AU-PRINCE.
WE SPOKE TO OUR GUEST.
I'M CONFUSED BY THE MESSAGE.
IT APPEARS TO BE THE PRESIDENT
IS THAT THE POINT?
>> IF YOU LOOK AT THE TRAJECTORY
WE FIRST RAN THEM LAST YEAR ON
FOX DURING THE SUPER BOWL.
>> Tucker: WE APPRECIATE THAT.
>> I'M SURE YOU DO AND SURE THE
COMPANY DID.
THE AD WAS REALLY FOCUSSED ON
THE SAME SUBJECT MATTER THIS AD
IS FOCUSSED ON WHICH IS THE
CONCEPT OF WE ACCEPT.
WE'RE A PEOPLE-TO-PEOPLE BASED
AND HAVE OVER 250 MILLION USERS
AND 191 COUNTRIES AND WE DO
BELIEVE -- OUR MISSION IS TO
ALLOW ANYONE TO BELONG ANYWHERE
AND SO LAST YEAR ON THE SUPER
BOWL WE RAN AN AD ABOUT WE
ACCEPT WHICH EMBRACED THE IDEA
OF INCLUSION AND DIVERSITY IN
RESPONSE TO THE TRAVEL BAN THAT
TOOK PLACE.
OVER THE COURSE OF THE YEAR
MISSION OF ALLOWING ANYONE TO
BELONG ANYWHERE.
SO THIS AD --
>> Tucker: THE QUESTION IS
MONEY.
ARE YOU AT CHURCH NOW?
WHAT?
>> EX TOLES THE VIRTUES OF SOME
PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT IN
IT FOR MONEY.
I DOUBT YOU TAKE PAY.
YOU'RE IN IT FOR MORAL
SATISFACTION.
>> HOW MUCH DO WE MAKE ON EACH
AIRBNB.
I'M ATTACKING THE
MISCHARACTERIZATION OF IT AS A
MISSIONARY ORGANIZATION.
[MULTIPLE SPEAKING]
>> Tucker: THE POINT IS CLEAR
WE'RE A VIRTUOUS COMPANY AND
WE'RE GOOD AND THE PRESIDENT'S
EVIL.
IS THAT A GOOD PLAY TO YOU SO
SAY WE'RE A VIRTUOUS COMPANY.
WE'RE NOT IN IT FOR THE MONEY,
WE'RE JUST GOOD PEOPLE.
>> IT'S GOOD THAT YOU'RE NOT
WRITING AD SCRIPTS.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO LOOK AT WHAT
THE AD SAYS.
IT SAYS THERE'S BEAUTIFUL PEOPLE
AND BEAUTIFUL PLACES.
IT'S TO ALLOW ANYONE TO BELONG
ANYWHERE.
WE CREATED THE TECHNOLOGY TO
CREATE ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY FOR
THEM OFFLINE FROM DIFFERENT
BACKGROUNDS.
>> Tucker: THAT'S GREAT.
I'M JUST SAYING -- HOLD ON, YOU
IN THIS AD SAY, COME TO HAITI.
PROTECTION THROUGH DOWNTOWN
PORT-AU-PRINCE RECENTLY AND IF
SO, HOW'D IT GO?
>> I WALKED AND SPENT A COUPLE
NIGHTS IN A TOWNSHIP IN SOUTH
AFRICA OUTSIDE OF CAPE TOWN.
>> Tucker: HOLD ON --
>> HAVE YOU BEEN TO THOSE
PLACES?
>> Tucker: YES, I HAVE.
>> HAVE YOU SPENT THE NIGHT IN
SOME OF THESE TOWNSHIPS?
LET'S BE POLITE AND ANSWER
THE RICHEST PLACE IN SOUTH
AFRICA.
I KNOW A BIT ABOUT HAITI AND I'M
>> I THINK WHAT IS WRONG IS TO
CAST ASPERSIONS ON AN ENTIRE
PEOPLE IN AN ENTIRE COUNTRY.
>> Tucker: I AGREE.
>> ALL THE DATA SUPPORTS THIS.
THE BEST WAY TO BREAK DOWN
DIFFERENCES IS TO HAVE PEOPLE
FROM DIFFERENT BACKGROUNDS SPEND
TIME WITH ONE ANOTHER.
NOT TO CRITICIZE THEM OR CONDEMN
THEM OR IMPUGN THEM BUT FOR
PEOPLE TO OFF-LINE SPEND TIME
WITH ONE ANOTHER.
>> Tucker: WILL YOU PLEDGE TO
PERSONALLY, WITH YOUR FAMILY, GO
ON VACATION IN HAITI NOT AT SOME
RICH PEOPLE RESORT BUT IN
DOWNTOWN PORT-AU-PRINCE, THE
CAPITAL CITY AND SPEND A WEEK
JUST IN ORDER TO GET THAT
CULTURAL POLLINIZATION AND COME
>> IF YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT MY
FAMILY, I'M HAPPY TO.
MY FAMILY MAY HAVE MORE CULTURAL
DIVERSITY THAN YOU'RE AWARE OF.
I'M NOT ATTACKING YOUR FAMILY --
DID YOU GO TO PORT-AU-PRINCE OR
NOT?
>> WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO ANSWER
THE QUESTION?
THE ANSWER SO YOUR QUESTION IS
WE'RE PLANNING A TRIP TO AFRICA
WHERE WE'RE ACTUALLY GOING TO BE
GOING TO SOME OF THE TOWNSHIPS I
TALKED ABOUT.
>> Tucker: I HOPE THAT OCCURS ON
YOUR TRIP TO THE CARIBBEAN.
>> YOUR QUESTION IS GETTING AT
WHETHER I, AND MY FAMILY, AM
WILLING TO TRAVEL TO PLACES IN
THE WORLD THAT PEOPLE TYPICALLY
DO NOT TRAVEL TO.
>> Tucker: MY QUESTION IS ARE
YOU GOING TO PORT-AU-PRINCE,
HAITI.
>> I'M HAPPY TO TAKE MY FAMILY
TO THESE TYPES OF PLACES IN THE
PAST.
I DO BELIEVE IN WHAT OUR
PLATFORM IS TRYING TO DO WHICH
IS ULTIMATELY TO TAKE PEOPLE
BACKGROUNDS -- NOW, I GET YOU
MAY NOT DO THAT.
>> Tucker: I'M WONDERING DID YOU
GET ORDAINED BEFORE YOU GOT THIS
JOB?
>> YOU DIDN'T ASK THESE
QUESTIONS LAST YEAR WHEN WE RAN
THE AD ON FOX DURING THE SUPER
BOWL.
DID YOU ASK THE QUESTIONS LAST
YEAR?
>> Tucker: ENJOY YOUR TIME IN
PORT-AU-PRINCE.